monday tuesday
wednesday wednesday
wednesday again wednesday i feel like
we've done this before
wednesday does anybody else notice this
wednesday how do i break this time loom
could you tell if you've been living the
same day
all over again how many times did
today really happen and
if you were trapped in a loop how would
you get out of it
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you got stuck in a time loop
you know that feeling of deja vu when
you just
know you've seen this happen before
now imagine if your entire day is a big
deja vu moment and tomorrow and then the
day after tomorrow
and nobody seems to notice it but you
what would you do to break the cycle and
what would happen if you died i
understand you've got a lot of questions
but before we start
i'd like to introduce you to some
mind-blowing science
as weird science theories often do this
one starts with albert einstein's theory
of general relativity
basically the idea is that the three
dimensions of space
and a dimension of time are joined
together
in a continuum called space-time
gravity can bend this space-time which
theoretically makes time travel possible
that is if you have access to a big
enough black hole
or to a time machine like a tipler
cylinder
we included instructions on how to build
one in another video
you might want to check that out without
getting into too much detail
a time machine like a tipler cylinder
could
create a closed time-like curve
[Music]
in this system a particle could go back
in time
to where it started we don't understand
quantum physics enough to know if these
closed
time-like curves could or couldn't exist
but
for the sake of this scenario we'll
assume they are
possible and are a result of space-time
folding upon itself
[Music]
what would this mean for you
well for one thing you could travel back
into yesterday
and start your day all over again in
that case
reliving the same day again wouldn't be
surprising to you
you'd be in control of when to go back
to the future
and if you die during one of those
travels you wouldn't wake up in your bed
the morning before
that would be the real end for you
but you wouldn't be restricted to only
going back to yesterday
you could travel back to the time when
you were born
take a heck of a trip down memory lane
no matter how far in the past you went
you wouldn't change it in any way
you wouldn't create any paradoxes like
killing your yesterday's
self or whatever else you might come up
with
ironically what's preventing you from
creating any time paradoxes
is called a predestination paradox
in a closed time-like curve when you
travel to the past
you've always been part of that past
your presence wouldn't change a thing
[Music]
at the same time if you find yourself
reliving yesterday
that could mean that somebody put you in
a time machine and
sent you one day back in that case you
should
just go on with your day till it's over
and the next day
you'd be living in tomorrow
if you want to geek out on time
traveling here's some food for thought
maybe closed time-like curves aren't
closed at all what if instead
an alternate timeline would appear every
time you traveled to the past
then you'd continue living in an
alternate universe and
you wouldn't be able to go back to your
original one
unless you open some kind of portal to a
parallel world but
that's a story for another what if and
if you want to learn more about time
loops and closed timeline
curves check out our what if discussed
episode
where we welcomed danny rubin the
screenwriter of the
ultimate time loop movie groundhog day
you